so we've got this fraction written here
2/3 what I want you to do is pause this
video and try to think of any other
fractions that are the same that are
equivalent to this fraction right over
here that essentially represent the same
number so to do that let's let's
visualize what two-thirds is so let me
draw a hole here let me draw a hole and
I'm gonna divide it into three equal
sections so that is my hole we drive
three equal sections I'm gonna try to
draw make them as equal as I I can do a
little better job than that so that's
one two three three equal sections and
so two-thirds would represent two out of
those three equal sections
so I second spray-paint this so that's
one third right over here and then this
is two-thirds so we have two of the
three equal sections so that is
two-thirds and I'll let me copy and
paste that so we can think about other
ways to represent this fraction so copy
and then let me paste it I'll do it once
and then and I'll do it another time and
I could do this multiple times but I'll
do two other times right over here so
there's a couple of things we can do the
first option is we could take this and
we could divide we could draw a
horizontal line that draws that divides
each of these three sections into two
sections so let's do that into two
sections
so now how many equal sections do I have
I have one two three four five six equal
sections six equal sections and how many
of those equal sections are actually
shaded in now well we see it's one two
three four four six so notice four six
is the exact same fraction of the whole
as two-thirds these are equivalent
fractions we could say that 2/3 is equal
to 4/6 now we could do something very
similar instead of dividing each of
those each of these thirds into two we
could divide each of these thirds into
three so I could draw three horizontal
lines here so let's see one two three so
now I have divided what was in three
equal sections and I have three
many three times as many sections I have
one two three four five six seven eight
nine equal sections and then which of
those are actually shaded in we have 1 2
3 4 5 6 6 so 2/3 which is equal to 4 6
is also equal to six ninths these are
all all three of these are equivalent
fractions two-thirds four six and six
nines and if you were to put them on the
number line the same thing what happens
let's do that let's draw a number line
here let's say that's a zero and I'm
just gonna focus on between zero and one
and obviously we can go beyond that go
beyond that and let's divide it first
into thirds so this is one-third and
two-thirds so we already know this is
this would represent one-third and this
is two-thirds it's we've gone to of the
equal spaces of the three on the way to
one we've divided the section between
zero and two one and two three equal
spaces now what would four sixths be
well now we just have to divide this
into six equal spaces so one two three
four five six and four sixths that would
be four out of the six spaces a lot on
the way to one so one two three four
so this number is also equal to four six
and you could do the same thing if you
wanted to think about ninths so instead
of instead of dividing each of so what
we could do we could put one two three
four five six seven eight nine now I've
split this part of our number line
between 0 and 2 and 1 into 9 equal
spaces well what would six ninths be
well 1 2 3 4 5 6
once again the exact same point of the
number line it's an equivalent fraction
six nines is equal to 2/3 is equal to
4/6